When we send a mission to Mars to search for
ancient life, where should it land?
A crater filled with glass… yes, GLASS…
might be a good place to start.
Hello, I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer
for Discovery News and today I wanted to take
a quick trip onto the tantalizing surface
of Mars.
As depicted in the AWESOME-looking trailer
for the new Matt Damon movie “The Martian,”
the Red planet looks like a barren and poisonous
place.
To survive, Damon’s character, astronaut
MARK WATNEY, must “science the shit” out
of his temporary habitat to survive after
being left for dead by his crew.
But as our armada of space robots are showing
us, Mars hasn’t always been the dry and
deadly environment it is now -- Mars was once
a wet world containing the ingredients for
life and it looks like meteorite craters may
be the best place to look for any ancient
lifeforms that could have evolved millions
of years ago.
We all know that the Red Planet is littered
with craters and interesting geological features,
and it just so happens that NASA’s getting
very familiar with the minerals that cover
the Martian surface.
In new research, one particular instrument
on board NASA’s Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter
called CRISM has been used to look deep into
a few impact craters to look for glass.
But why glass?
Well, in 2014, researchers headed by Brown
University found glass deposits at the bottom
of an Argentinian meteorite impact crater
that was formed millions of years ago.
Entombed inside this glass was organic material
that was existing at the site when the meteorite
hit Earth.
Glass can form when minerals in rock are exposed
to sudden heating -- so the extreme impact
pressures and searing heat generated during
a meteorite impact can produce certain types
of glasses.
Like those Jurassic era mosquitos entombed
inside amber, any ancient organic matter can
be “frozen in time” within this glass,
providing us with a cool look into a biological
time capsule dating back millions of years.
So, by turning their gaze to Mars, researchers
pondered whether Mars also has glass in its
craters, potentially also containing biosignatures
of hypothetical ancient Mars life.
But the spectroscopic signature of glass on
Mars is very hard to detect.
In an effort to confront this, the Brown team
put similar powdered minerals found on Mars
into an oven and heated it to form glass in
the lab.
They then studied light reflected off the
lab glass to measure its spectroscopic fingerprint.
Then, using CRISM, the researchers sought
out regions on Mars that generated a similar
fingerprint when compared with the lab sample.
And then they saw it, craters on Mars containing
glassy material!
The most exciting thing is that one of the
craters found to contain glass is HARGRAVES
CRATER near NILI FOSSAE, a 400-mile-long trough
in the Martian surface.
And it just so happens that this is one of
the landing site options for NASA’s Mars
2020 sample return mission.
Should the rover find glass in that area,
and might we be able to analyse the stuff
the samples contain, could the glass have
the fossilized remains of ancient Mars microbes
inside?
Who knows, but it would be cool to find out.
Do you think we should send a manned expedition
to search for Mars fossils?
Let us know what you think in the comments
below, and if you’re interested in how we’re
currently looking for Mars life, check out
Amy’s recent video.